hey everyone how's it going welcome back
to my JavaScript crash course for
beginners series what I'm going to talk
about today is variables specifically
what I'll cover is what is a variable
and why are they necessary in
programming and then we'll get to how to
create and use them in JavaScript and
we'll also go over some examples now if
you remember back to my first tutorial I
have my environment set up already
I've already opened my terminal window
and launched my Python server on the
left side of the screen I've got my
editor open this time I got it nicely
zoomed in instead of having to that in
post so you'll be able to see everything
a lot more clearly on the right I've got
Chrome open so we're gonna go and open
developer tools now get the console
showing and let's navigate to localhost
so we've got the index.html page showing
we've got that loaded and so we're all
ready to go and if I make any
modifications to the files and hit
reload everything should just start
appearing in the browser and console
just like the previous j/s tutorial so
let's go and do that
to begin what are variables and how do
they work now keep in mind this whole
thing this tutorial on JavaScript is for
absolute beginners if you're confident
that you super familiar with what
variables are and just want to skip
ahead then by all means go ahead but we
should make this section pretty brief
anyway so what are variables variables
are really a fundamental tool or concept
in programming they act as containers
for a piece of information stepping away
from the computer for a minute if you
imagine that you're sitting at dinner
trying to figure out the total cost of
you and your friends meal let's assume
that every meal is only a main course in
a drink now you could just say well my
burger was $10 and my drink was four and
their fish and chips was 12 and they
didn't have a drink that would be that
would be $26 in total and that works and
you've got your answer but if we tweak
the problem a little bit now and you
were to describe this to someone how do
you calculate the cost of a meal for two
people well in that case you would say
something more along the lines of it's
the cost of person a is main meal plus
their drink plus the person B main meal
plus their drink and what you've done in
that case is you've substituted the
specific values for sort of symbolic
names for things and then you described
how to combine those values in terms of
the symbolic names instead so now
knowing that the total cost is let's
just write this down to little
it goes mule 1 + 3 1 + 2 + 2 - you've
got four variables here you've got you
know 1 VL 2 & 1/2 and that's all the
variables are there a way for you as a
programmer to give a name to a piece of
information in the program you're
writing and later you can refer to it
using that name and you can write
equations and you can do things like
that
using these symbolic names that can be
filled in later with different data
rather than having to use the specific
values right away like in the first
example where it was ten dollars and
four dollars and twelve dollars you can
express things in terms of the symbolic
names instead now that we've talked a
bit about what variables are from a more
abstract point of view let's talk about
them in JavaScript and how they're
created and used now as you recall a
variable is you could think of it as a
container for a piece of data that you
want to save and manipulate in in
JavaScript we can declare variables to
store data for use throughout the
execution of the program and we can do
this using a special set of keywords I'm
gonna go ahead right now and create a
variable in the code using a keyword
called let in JavaScript as in most
programming languages there are special
reserved keywords that you can't reuse
there's a whole bunch of them it's not
overwhelming but you'll just sort of
learn them organically as you program
more and more so there are three key
words for declaring variables and I'll
list them right now there's let Const
and var so that
and they all have very specific meanings
and some subtleties between
unfortunately this early on in the
series I can't go into detail on what
those differences are just yet but I'll
dedicate an entire video to that later
we need to cover some more advanced
topics like scoping before a description
of the differences here will make any
sense to anybody for now though use that
ignore Const and a bit of attention but
using VAR it's just not good practice
these days I know I kind of get it I see
tutorials all the time people using it
showing that in videos but yeah don't do
that
experts generally frown on its usage and
there's even automated code checkers
like es lint that have rules
specifically in place to explicitly flag
your code if you do so so if you want to
try say contributing to a major project
that uses es lint maybe you're trying to
build up your resume or something like
that you might have a hard time because
it's going to flag you and you're going
to have to make corrections to your code
now the world isn't going to fall apart
we use bar it works there's huge long
programs that can be written work
perfectly fine using it but it's an
outdated way of doing things and if
you're going to learn JavaScript you
might as well learn the most up-to-date
way of doing so for the time being let's
use the reserved keyword let to declare
the variable and we have to give it a
name so let's just go back here to do
we're gonna give it a name now naming
variables is done in a very specific way
you can't just give them arbitrary names
involving random characters or spaces
there's a very specific subset of
characters that are considered valid for
names so here's the general way to name
them you can use alphanumeric characters
that means that you can use a to Zed
you can use capitals or lowercase so a
does ed or ages head and you can use
numbers so zero through nine
but they can't start at the beginning of
the name and you can also use under
school and the reason being that in
JavaScript like in most programming
languages a lot of these other
characters like let's say that you're
looking at your keyboard and you see
star the plus symbol the end symbol the
hash exclamation mark there's there's
lots of them just look at your keyboard
these are often reserved for special use
they have special meaning within the
language for example in JavaScript the
star sort of the star it generally means
multiply so allowing you to insert that
into the middle of a name would make
things really really confusing so you
just can't do it anyway let's get back
to naming like I said alphabetic or
underscore first then alphanumeric and
underscores all you want we'll call this
foo and at the end of the variable
declaration you add two semicolon so
semicolon so the whole thing might look
like that's right a few more out at X
but
so as you can see each of those names
adhered to those rule
I used alphabetic characters or
underscores first I could use capitals
or lower cases and I can use numbers but
not at the beginning of the variable
name now we can actually run this so I'm
just gonna go and run this here just
going to make this a bit bigger and as
you can see nothing really happened in
actuality something did happen those
variables were all declared in the code
it's just that nothing happens and so
you don't see anything in the console
the way that you can tell something
happened is that you have to use them in
some way let's just look at the sources
real quick you can see here whoops so
let's go back and use them a little bit
and then we can see the result in the
logs open the log again span that a
little bit I'll get rid of these old
ones let x equals 2
and here we go over reload the page and
as you can see after we reload the page
you two showed up in there two showed up
there and the logs after the other two
messages that we wrote so that's kind of
cool now remember that we said that
variables are containers for information
there's symbolic names there's symbolic
names for you to refer to them but the
information they store can change so
let's change the value of our X variable
so again we go back to Chrome and
refresh and you can see that it printed
too and then immediately afterwards it
printed three which means at the time
that it printed too over here the value
of X was 2 you can see over here and
then over here changes to 3 and then it
prints 3 both of these log statements
are identical they just console dot log
X but each time X contains a different
value so let's get a little fancier now
and declare a second variable and we'll
call it Y
so we just logged these out it'll just
say two and one which is expected now if
we go here and we say x equals y so what
do you think will happen in this case if
you're thinking that the X variable will
now contain the same value that the Y
variable had that's right that's what's
gonna happen
just copy these log statements again so
down here and you can see now that X is
1 and Y is 1 and we can do some more
things too
let's declare a third variable now this
is gonna do exactly what you think it's
going to do which is
it shows up at three because one plus
two is three and X is two and Y is one
and remember how I said you can only use
alphanumeric characters and the variable
names this is a good example why X plus
y is literally the value of x plus the
value of y it's not a variable this
named X plus y so now what happens if
you don't name them properly it's pretty
simple javascript is just going to throw
an exception in your code won't run
properly so let's name a few improperly
here we go and we're gonna run that or
so we're gonna call that x plus y
because that plus is not a valid
character because plus is not a valid
character for a name and uncaught syntax
error unexpected token plus which means
you aren't supposed to use a plus in the
name let's use some spaces so let the
cost of a meal equal to again uncaught
syntax error unexpected identifier
basically meaning that it expected a
single name and it got a whole bunch of
different ones because with spaces here
let's put some quotes in there uncut
syntax error again unexpected strictmode
reserved word so you know now roughly
what constitutes a valid name and what
constitutes an invalid name the last
thing we should talk about our best
practices when naming when you're
writing code one of the best things to
imagine is could someone who's never
read the code look at it and understand
clearly and quickly what it's doing
variable naming is really important here
because naming something like let's go
bad you've got a whole bunch of code
here you go n equals some magic number
and that y equals 3 and that an acronym
DSF Oh P equal 78 those aren't
descriptive in the slightest
they don't convey any meaning to the
reader or engineer or co-worker who has
to work with you and your code later you
might not even be around to describe
what it's doing and they're trying to
figure out what this means in general I
try to use names that convey meaning and
are as descriptive as possible to within
reason of course
so you use names like
no you look at those two names and you
are reasonably certain what values they
hold what I would personally recommend
doing is hopping on Google and searching
for JavaScript style guide let's just do
that now as you can see there's a whole
bunch of them there's the Google style
guide there's the Google style guide
there's the Airbnb one there's the
JavaScript standard style Google's is a
good one you can look at naming here and
you can see that the naming conventions
that they use are pretty similar
descriptive names don't worry about
making them too small you want to make
them more immediately understandable not
buy a new reader don't use abbreviations
that are on them that are ambiguous or
unfamiliar those are all solid bits of
advice and they really do help making
your code more understandable and more
maintainable later for someone else so
that about wraps up this video in the
series stay tuned for the next video in
my JavaScript crash course series I plan
to talk about data types so I hope you
enjoyed this and I'll see you again soon
Cheers